c'est une compétition internationale
puis il propose des missions qui dure
plusieurs années puis la mission au
moment où elle est formulée est fait
pour que ça ne soit pas faisable avec
des technologies existence on est dans
un gymnase n'a rien qui a des robots le
type aspirateur ménager au sol qui bouge
et nous enfoncer un peu injuste siens
énergie pour que le drone s'oriente pour
interagir avec le groupe qui nous
empêcher de franchir certaines lignes et
les orienter nos clients
mais toute cette façon autonome on
n'intervient d'aucune manière dans l'anc
est ce qu'il fait et non seulement ça il
ya aucun et aucun comportement
préprogrammés nous on question agent d
algérie de décision donc lui puisse
réagir
ah qu'est ce qui se passe en temps réel
mon apport at elle est hantée par
rapport aux mains une par rapport au
plafond on appellerait tous les épées
donc on a beaucoup de contraintes par
rapport à la compétition